[Music]
[Applause]
all right
he's kevin miles the actor he's jake
from state farm
he joins us now kevin let's get right to
it since you've been looking a little
bit more buff than ever
are you taking performance-enhancing
drugs
absolutely not no no no no i uh
i've been doing p90x3 i mean i've been
doing that for years with tony horton
and
working out with those guys at his place
and i mean they're just
they're just beasts they're they're
believe it or not even though he's in
his 60s he's
way leaps and bounds stronger than me
and
uh i just take note from him really now
i mean i'm asking on behalf of aaron
rodgers and patrick mahomes they've been
on
the last uh you know a couple of weeks
i've had them both on separately and
you know mahomes said he might put in
his contract you have to wear a
long-sleeve shirt from now you used to
wear the long sleeve shirt kevin a
sweater
and all of a sudden we unleash the guns
so
this is how the rumors start this is how
they start
that was definitely a a wardrobe and
everyone there i mean
then again we were shooting in austin so
i think we were going through a heat
wave and i mean it was 130 degrees so i
was appreciative of the shirt
but uh yeah yeah they they put that
medium on and
you know really kind of uh let some
things pop out
so i was you know it could have been
a little nervous so they gave me some
confidence they're like hey man you look
good i was like really yeah yeah i was
like
all right then all right let's go out
there all right so yeah but it looks
like you got a smedium on like that
that shirt hey yeah i normally wear a
large extra large uh and that was
definitely a medium
uh but you know uh it was right in the
middle of um
uh quarantine so those were my workouts
where i was
uh you know telling myself you know why
am i just lift as heavy as i can you
know i just have weights here i don't
have a treadmill or
a bike or anything to get the lean
cardio going did you party pump
before going on camera
no no but i did work out uh right after
okay um
i i'm a night workout person i i
definitely can't really work out in the
morning unless i'm
and unless i know i have a very full day
and then
and then it's like all right i have to
so that way i can sleep and then wake up
the next day
how many people auditioned for jake from
state farm
oh wow yeah they uh they told me that
they
auditioned people in new york la and
chicago
i was in the la group and i remember
there was
there was a good amount of people for
the audition but the callback
there were i mean there were
like 40 or 50 people there at that
callback uh
uh some really solid actors that that
even i'm i'm a fan of you know and i was
definitely really nervous going in just
because
you know you see these actors that you
you admire and you've seen before
going in for this role and it you know
you're just like oh crap i know they're
great
okay wait are these famous actors or
just
sort of well-known in the acting
community uh i think well-known the
acting community you know
he's not like leonardo dicaprio
let
yeah there were some really really good
heavy hitters and um
i i really just think that i uh just
happened to test well with the focus
groups
um and and and i don't know i i always
wanted to make it something that
felt close to me close to who i am you
know and
and at least from the spots that i was
auditioning i didn't know it would be
you know maybe 100 commercials i thought
maybe it was two spots
how did it change your life uh my
schedule is definitely very packed
um that's pretty much that and
not nothing else i mean i think the best
thing is that you know
uh when i'm approached out in public you
know uh
it's it's all good energy and that helps
you know it's not like i
came out and was a villain you know
people know me as me pretty much
and uh and that's pretty much that you
know do you wear
a red shirt out in public no no no i do
my best to
to just keep it um to keep it me i i i
tend to wear a lot of
all black sometimes you know um
and you know uh some graphic tees that
my friends have made
you know i'm very very low like that i i
love the pandemic
specifically because of the sweatpants
you know that that we're all
kind of rocking these days uh better
actor between the two rogers or mahomes
um i think rogers is very seasoned so
mahomes has a a phenomenal confidence
on set you know so he's very comfortable
in oh we're doing this we can play
around and do this
but i mean aaron he's a he's a champion
for sure i
i was actually shocked you know it was
more like a wow you're
really good you're making great choices
you're you're giving me things to play
with
that i didn't know we were going to do
with the scene so i mean
i he he's all around just just
phenomenal so he does great i think you
can see it in the commercials i mean
he's
he's just on point he's just right there
he's dropped into the moment
and yeah he's great how nervous were you
uh i i was i was half and half nervous i
think i i only get nervous
after the fact you know that i don't
know what they're gonna choose
you know for the the final edits or the
cuts uh in the moment i'm more so
just trying to make sure that i uh uh
just do a good job give some takes you
know
uh make sure i don't waste everyone's
time and uh
and mess everything up that's that's
pretty much me so
yeah i wasn't really nervous i was just
i was more excited and ready you know
ready to
to act with these guys and ready to do
something fun and just
you know uh relate and make it our own
if the packers were playing the chiefs
in the super bowl who would you be
rooting for
that's a it's a question i never even
asked myself
i hate those i love those guys man
i uh i genuinely couldn't say
i'd be happy for both uh aaron to me is
is like like uncle aaron you know he's a
good guy
you talked about talking about halo
together you know you can't you can't
knock a guy that loves playing halo
you know and uh patrick you know we're
closer to age and he just feels like my
my brother
so it feels as if i i i i hate to see
any of them
not win a championship they're both
champions and
and i mean even when they listening to
them talk to each other on set
you can just know like their dedication
to the game is so great that
i want them to win you know they are the
mvps and
yeah i i uh man
i want them to get i both want them to
have that trophy i can't lie
is there is there a downside as an actor
that you get a role like there's there's
there's a great upside but
now you're jake from state farm and i
know you've been in other commercials
and you have
i'm sure goals to be in movies or tv
shows right
any any concerns about being jake from
state farm
that's a downside um i personally don't
have any concerns i know that
there's other people you know they
they'll say you'll get stuck but i think
it's a new day and age for entertainment
uh in a sense you know there's a lot of
social media stars that are able to
break out from doing skits online just
because people are familiar
with them um i come from a theater
background anyway so doing jake
it's so close to me i'm not trying to
play a
character of anything you know i'm just
trying to make it where
it's me always talking to my best friend
or my family member
and i think from there i can you know
put that into other roles as well as
when i grow as an actor and i really
kind of
you know really mold myself and get
better just on film i think that i'll be
able to branch out and do things that
you know do the works that i that i love
or you know
want to pursue at the time so i think
it's actually more of a helping
like a stepping stone you know i don't
know if you hang out with the other
insurance people
like flo like like dr rick if you if you
see them
like you guys is there a little
fraternity there you know i've never
seen them before uh out in public but
you know i i they all do a great job so
i wouldn't
i wouldn't mind hanging out with them
and and talking
and just you know just just shooting
from the hip
just what what life is like being one of
the uh
uh a spokesperson you know
flo looks like she could be some fun
yeah yeah yeah she she looks like she's
definitely um
i i think i saw her one time at
groundlings and
uh i mean she was just great you know
she just seems like she's
living life and enjoying doing the art
and and what she wants to do
and that's definitely you know an
inspiration for
any actor is to to just keep going and
keep exploring and having fun with it
you know not being so
tied in of i have to be this or this or
this
you know everyone has their own personal
goals of what they want to be as an
actor and i think that
you should follow them and have fun with
it that's what we're supposed to do uh
before i say goodbye kevin uh let's see
the gun show
let me give give me give me both give me
both right arm you want left arm
both barrels okay okay there you go yep
right now you know it's a little it's
smaller so i
i gained some weight for for uh the nfl
spots i wanted to make it you know look
as if i could
you know play a pickup game with these
guys and we you know really
we'd really do some damage uh and then
for the nba stuff you know i want to be
a little smaller you know leaner
yeah yeah just leaner you know uh kevin
thank you
you're like de niro you're like the de
niro of of uh
insurance like insurance commercials
like you you know you know
whatever it takes to play the role yeah
yeah i'm trying to be the christian bale
of these commercials
filled up so hey uh congrats on the
success man write it as long as you can
and uh we appreciate your
time thanks for your sense of humor kev
yeah i appreciate you and i love what
you do you're amazing
thank you kevin thank you kevin miles
that's uh jake from state farm